I'm doing this I was like it's not like
I'm like on the walls just
you know Lionel Richie and [__] yeah I'm
not [__] Jamiroquai
it's so annoying dude it's actually
Lionel Richie not did you remember quite
no he's like going back and forth you
know he walks all over he walks on the
ceiling too dude all right so sue me so
sue me
wrong
[Music]
not everything's right that needs to be
on I know and I there we go because
because he [__] ruined it yeah
um and popping and
um and popping yeah Method Man the way
you're doing what method manual isn't
that how he does it the like no okay I
know on and Poppin is uh what's his name
Young MC I thought it was DJ quit no
okay I'm also right about other stuff
though so it evens out so it's fine all
right great that's great welcome to the
show Lifeline
um welcome to the show lifeline and
welcome to
dangly earringville
you ever been a dangly earringville
that's okay
probably not because it's population one
old lady
I'm not an old lady though I'm a young
man yeah well you gotta dang the earring
and you got it before I did but that's
okay because I was busy getting [__]
you added up yeah yeah and I swore God
bleep it out sorry you have so many
Shadows that you can't even show
everybody I can't yet no they're not
healed so but I do I do what I want and
I do it on my own time and some of them
I won't be seen for anybody but I saw
you saw I saw it and you know and nobody
knows what it is
are they ever gonna know like yeah well
it's on my arms so yeah it's creeping
out yeah I know he's trying to say
that's the worst thing to do the tattoo
is right under coming out under a shirt
I don't know if you guys can see but
what it's saying is let me be seen no
it's not it's gone like this hey dude
just let you know he's this sexy that's
what's doing it because being because
having a lot of tattoos is sexy and I'm
sexy
okay so you think it's sexy when guys
have a lot of tattoos yep
yeah in a in a gay way I think that oh
and I'm gay oh so how's that
um that was so unceremonious the way you
yep came out of the closet yep but uh I
will say uh oh there's news here I'm
shooting my special uh in Minneapolis uh
April 1st and the first show sold out
but their second show still tickets if
you want to be a part of that and who's
directing it Steven Spielberg that's not
true how would it be
if that's if that's who directed it
Steven Spielberg and uh Guillermo del
Toro co-directing wow wow that's amazing
I didn't even know that yeah okay no you
know who's directing it yeah I do he's a
little guy I like to call
okay
yeah well we all call him that because
that's his name
um but yeah I will be in Minneapolis I
will be in Austin I will be in uh
different places you know and gave up uh
with Tulsa
and Kansas City that's what's up dude
you're gonna be in Sugarland Sugarland
no I already did it Sugar Land I already
did it how did the guy correct you again
I don't know it doesn't matter though
huh I'll be in Midland Texas
um Columbus Cincinnati and Boise and
more dates coming up oh Milwaukee and uh
Utah
laughs
so yeah that's all good that's a lot of
you said there's a lot of places that
you didn't say I know but you know
you'll be in Salt Lake I got a lot go at
chrisley.com and check it out you know
being uh let's stop moving it oh stop
stop moving it's doing it like look here
okay uh anyway you know you have a
question for us on this show click the
link in the description below or just
simply go to watch lifeline.com if you
want a one-on-one advice session with me
you want to get down and dirty you want
to get in the muck you want to get in
the mire you want to we get it talk
about real serious Darkness stuff we get
it privacy come to me book a session
mattdelia.com we'll get it taken care of
all right and the lifeline merch is fire
lifelinemerch.com lifelinemerch.com not
fire is in the website anyway I know
that's why you repeated it well
obviously you did too many drinks too
many hats all right so this is not a
regular Coke but those little ones are
kind of a little bit it's also zero
it's zero calories in little way less of
a Coke anyway yeah but pretty soon
there's no sugar in this
yo
dude bro burping there's uh there's no
sugar in this yeah I know that's what a
Coke Zero is man what's even in it then
you know what I'm saying I'll tell you
what's in it cancer yeah chemicals
what's worse this or regular Coke it
depends if you want to get fat or die
I'd rather oh I'd rather get fat we're
gonna die from fatness anyway you're
gonna die your thing doesn't even work
you want to die fat or you want to die
with cancer oh I want to duck fat
then you're drinking the wrong thing
yeah okay that's what I thought okay but
pretty soon you'll be like this
person's gonna be like this do you want
a Coke
like with the microscope
[Music]
oh wow that was a microscope the first
one was yeah my fingers would be too big
for you I look there's no regular Cokes
man it's okay man it's fine dude just
sit down and do the producer work I've
been misled I've been lied to wow for
himself
you want to cook let me go oh we don't
have any whoa hey look at here Chico
um so yeah so what you've been doing man
uh got the dangly earring about uh two
weeks ago oh wow I haven't seen you and
the woman who did it she asked me do you
want it right on the old because I used
to have my ears pierced oh right right
she said you want it right on the old uh
spot because that's where it was and I
said absolutely of course right but I
also thought there's no way she's gonna
get exactly yeah on it but you got it
exactly on it it's her job but she's so
good at it that's what you thank God she
did we knew more people like that who
are good so true would you get it done
what kiosk got them all uh uh the one
which more you mean no I'm saying
where'd you go what kiosk at the mall
like you were out there getting it in
the outside of Orange Julius just like I
basically was I was at the Glendale
Galleria yeah oh wow this was an
Armenian
she was not Armenian dog let me hey come
here hey you want it exactly where it
was dog she was she was Middle Eastern
but she was not Armenian this is uh the
waiver you have to sign this just in
case um I put my hands in your face I
know that a lot of times people don't
like their hands uh if someone put their
hands in my place in my face dude that's
it for them so how come when you you
think in your mind Armenians are only
talking about one version or another of
putting fingers in someone's face
because that's so disrespectful and hey
that's one thing I won't stand for dog
hey bro so is it the respect thing like
they think a lot about that's why they
love Scarface dude they love scars I saw
Scarface the other day dude for the
first time
how is that even possible dude it was
it's it because it's only seen Parts
it's one of those movies you only see
parts of you know if you're a loser yeah
but if you're a loser now you're a
non-loser dude how hilarious Al Pacino
literally just plays a [__] Cuban
I mean that's how it was didn't know
didn't know Tony Montana wasn't a real
person until I watched a movie well you
probably thought it because it's based
on a previous movie right by Howard
Hawks Howard Hawks who plays Scarface in
that one
Paul Mooney
really
mu and I oh no okay
Paul money uh from 1931 I think oh and
the only thing that's the same besides
the obvious horiz fall is that there's
there is the globe the world is really
that's what it is right yeah I knew that
and um
the world is yours it should say the
world is mine
right well that's actually that's
actually why it hasn't hesitated because
I was like wait does it yeah because no
it says the world's yours when I was
watching a movie I was like why doesn't
it say The World Is Mine He's So we get
this because it's supposed it's like
supposed to be a metaphor you can have
to have it apply it needs to be for you
not just
one person for the movie for the movie
and for the audience yeah right I know
but I didn't like that because it's like
I'm not dumb I get it but in the
original he actually sees it uh he sees
it up on the top of a building somewhere
oh and it like is it good a good movie I
mean it's you wouldn't like it but
Scarface a good movie the new one
yeah that's amazing you like it yeah
yeah dude cool push it to the limit so
many good things in them and then when
it goes welcome to the Limit that's my
favorite part when it goes push it to
the Limit and then talk about all like
going to keep it to the Limit and then
at the end it goes welcome to the Limit
like we've achieved got there yeah yep
it's telling a story yeah so uh I saw
Scarface I was in New York and I was in
Chicago and then you were only here so
great so I'm a world traveler you're not
yes where did you see Scarface on the
plane
your best place to see a movie no wrong
watch your Scarface on a plane is the
wrong thing to do well that's what I did
and that's the only time I was ever
gonna watch it so you should be great
hey dude why don't you like to watch
good movies oh EV why don't I like to
watch good movies oh oh you're talking
about that you're telling the talking to
a guy who watched Cloverfield last night
you're talking a guy who watched
Cloverfield
yeah the found foot dude have you seen
the new one the Cloverfield Paradox I
have Paradox Cloverfield Paradox saw
that on a plane too I only know I saw it
on Netflix the Cloverfield Lane is the
one other one Cloverfield what's
it's Cloverfield then it's 10
Cloverfield Lane that takes place many
years afterwards and then it's the
Cloverfield Paradox which takes place
before that you want a piece of trivia
yeah 10 Cloverfield Lane was never a
Cloverfield movie until after it was
shot then they added the part about how
they go outside
you're kidding me it was just a like a
uh chamber piece movie with a handful of
actors you're kidding me no dude and
then JJ Abrams who whose company had
produced it was like
that sucks time to expand the universe
and dude I'm telling you that makes it
sounds good I agree but I think it's
kind of smart it is smart they did it
for sure but like imagine that's not
what you made a plan imagine being the
film oh my God no dude yeah oh my god
dude that's crazy wow how did you know
that uh because I'm the guy this guy I
know about movies man wow are you sure I
mean I'm I wasn't there but yeah I'm
sure is that like one of those things
where they say the guy for the law
because they say the thing about loss
were like he he didn't really know what
he was doing he was just writing as he
was going Damon Lindelof or no no JJ
Abrams yeah Damon Damon Lindelof wrote
it right okay but right I know but but
it's but it was them too oh okay right
right and and they oh I've heard that
about life I'm saying like I don't know
overseas after the first season they
were like uh is that true I I don't know
but I don't know well then why are you
saying is it like that because I don't
believe [__] just because it's in the
[__] Zeitgeist no I know that that is
true about Cloverfield 10 Cloverfield
Lanes 10 different Cloverfield Lanes
what I don't understand is why here's
why I don't like Cloverfield why is it
called Cloverfield I don't know do you
know uh Anthony you're a dork
the entire time you guys been talking
about this I've been like oh yeah I know
that oh wow so what's up with why is it
is it called a Cloverfield was
originally the like
they were trying to keep it super secret
so it was originally that was like the
it's called something when a movie is
called something before it actually
comes out yeah I just kept it oh pissed
why though so now they're called the
monster clover in the monster in the in
a movie which is stupid and then it's 10
Cloverfield Lane it's like so they just
happen to live on a place called
Cloverfield lane lane I I don't like how
the Clover doesn't mean they were going
to call the movie you know what they
were gonna call the movie cheese what
yep don't know why no that's not true
yeah it is you made it up no I didn't
what movie was gonna be called cheese
Cloverfield why don't know why is it
called Cloverfield well Cloverfield
doesn't make people say why is it called
that cheese does
like cheese is a thing that everyone
knows what it is you know well
Cloverfield at least is a made-up thing
that people are like oh I don't need to
know what that is I'm just gonna see the
movie the whole time I was like why is
this [__] think of clover right right
right right it was called cheese I'd be
like this hilarity called the cheese
right right dude you know say right I
saw I don't say right I say right I know
I know I know we used to watch the thing
on MTV where the guy said right yeah
okay uh the grind the grind Eric Nice
put up a picture what is that what
you're doing that's what he's doing yeah
right right
right right and then I turned it into
like it's Jon Voight so now me in this
city and over here us two idiots we just
say John John John and only us we know
what we're talking about this is the
worst podcast known to man this is the
worst podcast and I will tell you this
dude Eric Nice is that's the worst last
name that's like your last name is
that's like your last name is arms
imagine didn't like that you cut me off
in the middle of it shut but it's fine
up dude it's like your last name is ice
are you done I'll wait now a few seconds
okay okay okay okay okay okay so what
was I even gonna say oh I wonder what
Eric nice looks like now though terrible
guys who are like that kind of handsome
look like she's nice after like [__]
yeah oh you can you can't say it it's 13
minutes in oh you just make the rules as
you go okay five minutes but yeah no I
get it
no doubt wow look at him he doesn't look
good he used to oh look how good that's
how it used to look though oh I thought
that's him now
that looks good yeah he did uh he did
balding well huh uh Daisy balding well
yeah you can tell because he's bald I
can't tell
you can tell because his hair starts
here okay I listen to yeah saluting you
saluting
um all right well you want to get into
the program okay or what or do we don't
talk about people that nobody [__]
knows about that was way too fast what
you said so Eric nice I bet everybody
remembers arcanese hi guys uh huge fan I
love your podcast it is literally my
lifeline Gets You Through My Days
however
quick backstory I am 26. I got married
at 23 divorced at 25. I took a year to
self-reflect love myself get get myself
right
um but she's just now getting back into
the dating field okay I'm originally
from Louisiana I've lived in La for five
six years now and getting back into the
dating scene has been absolute trash I
swear to God if I liked kitty cat I
would be a lesbian but your girl is
strictly dickly whoa I can't do it
however wait a second every guy that
I've had a fling with that I've gone on
dates with Etc that have allowed me to
meet their friends wanted me to meet
their friends we're in a group setting
and she's Southern she wants to meet the
friend she wants to see some of them I
make the friends laugh
Etc the guy literally will end it with
me because I am quote unquote too
sarcastic why am I making their friends
laugh why am I why do I have a
personality quality is basically what it
translates to yeah I don't understand
I'm not flirting with their friends I
try to make them laugh and they laugh
but they're like oh you you have too
much of they literally say you have too
much of a personality your personality
is intimidating I don't understand I
don't know if it's because I'm the
funniest person in the room and they
just get like mad about that I don't
even believe that with myself I just
like to get to know people like I'm
she's being pretty I'm Southern and if
you want me to meet your friends I'm not
just going to sit there and look pretty
hi I'm Tori no like I want to like get
to know you she's funny she has some
spunks she has some spice to work I
don't get why it's such a crime for me
to have a personality and want to make
people laugh but literally every guy
that I've gone on a date with has been
like
it's too much like later down the line
especially once meeting their friends
and their friends will message me after
and be like wait what happened why
aren't you with so and so like we hit it
off and they're like supposed to get a
lot of friends out of it he said that I
don't get it like you were fun he's just
must be going through it whatever but
it's literally been countless times yeah
I don't know any advice
would help but I got advice I hope I
don't have to just be like a bump on the
log 26.
I hope I can find my person somewhere
but I don't know like I feel like every
guy in La is like just used to girls
just sitting at a restaurant
about them but I give a [__] and I also
want to make you laugh and I want to
have a good time
is there a happy medium help yeah okay
so those guys that you're dating are
pieces of you nice and okay you don't
have to okay it's okay to swear now
pieces of Schneider it's not even that's
not how it would be it was pieces of
fish that's what it would be I'm making
it more German though okay it's it so I
don't know if I'd say the piece of [__]
but they're it's if you're like uh a
woman you know if you're if you're a guy
single guy and you're you meet a woman
that you like but and everything's cool
but otherwise other than the fact that
she has up too much of a personality is
like
that's not you're saying that you're
saying she has too much of a thing that
is good here's the thing that usually
you usually see honestly people who say
like oh I have too much of a personality
they seem annoying yeah right of course
she's not she actually seems like a very
sweet fun person to be around yeah okay
yeah so the guys that she must be
hanging out with are they I I don't know
them but they've got to just be like
insecure they were just like super
old-fashioned like really uptight
Christian except for she's in Italian
religion yeah no I know I'm saying
that's the thing that's the only kind of
guy who has an excuse to be that way if
you're from like 1951 and and like an
annoying not talking too much right yeah
exactly yeah right yeah uh yeah that's
weird that is a weird thing
um
I don't know I mean I like to talk and
and [__] and be funny and if uh you
know like my my wife is funny she's
funny
she's outgoing and stuff what are these
guys you know what here's my advice next
time if that happens again
ask what would you prefer then even if
you're not asked you're not you're not
positing well I can be that too I'm not
saying be desperate and like bend over
backwards to give this yeah what he
wants but put it back on him and be like
well I'm sorry what's what's like what's
the alternative you I have too much of a
personality you want just like an idiot
who sits there like what are you what
are you seeking that this isn't you know
I think they probably think they want
that but they don't actually really want
that these guys are I would say I don't
know how many guys it's been what three
four I don't know but they're lost
causes it's tough to date in La man it's
tough to date and you're you've been
through it already you've been married
you know you're married at a young age
like me in La it's a young age and I
have advice what they're probably if
they're if they're your age if they are
they're probably if yeah exactly I would
say maybe date older guys he probably
does SLA because I'm just saying that
sounds like a young person thing that's
true I don't know any 40 year old should
be like oh this woman she's got too much
of a personality but a young like
insecure person who like actually needs
to be the one who's funny and the center
of attention I could totally see it
going that way maybe date older guys if
they're your age or like under 30 years
older established guys know what they
want yeah and they're not insecure like
that yes figured it out yeah Yes
actually that was me 100 no we both kind
of wouldn't you wouldn't have got it I
walked she could fly like how they say
that yeah you cut me off just to say
what I was already saying which is all
good
uh okay but yeah that's the advice to
you appreciate you and I'm not also not
worried about it because she'll find I
mean yeah good good luck she's already
been married so she figured it out it
just sounds like you're on a bad run
yeah yeah yeah and that's not every guy
yeah a lot most guys that I know
actually say the opposite in fact many
guys I know are either having a hard
time with their current girlfriend or
their recent most recent girlfriend
because they're just like I don't know
like I wasn't like she wasn't really
like participating yeah
so it's like you could just you I think
you just had a run of the wrong guys
hurt to those guys right right right
right right right right okay cool
this is uh Logan from Alabama uh we are
actually in y'all's neck of the woods
right now for the very first time me and
my wife uh Shelby uh we are renting a
car uh in La which is kind of what it
seems to be the move yeah okay uh and it
got us thinking yeah um and really
butting heads
um I'm a Big Apple Maps guy and she is a
Waze girl which sounds strange but uh we
how do we get past this what do we what
do we mean
because it's causing a lot of of hard
feelings between the two of us okay and
uh we just kind of wanted to hear your
input what what do you guys like Apple
Maps or Waze thanks guys here's the
advice Logan stop being a
[__] piece of shination why because
Waze is so much better dude Apple map
sucks yeah but Apple Max Apple Maps
often sinks to your car
I hate that you're right it does yeah I
hate but I don't want it to right
because it's worse yeah
so yeah it's worse I can't tell you the
I mean the percent of times that I use
Waze and get there exactly at the at the
estimated time that they said I would
yeah it's unbelievable I use Apple Maps
and I don't even have a I have a Samsung
so it's amazing also the interface sucks
on Apple Maps oh really yes I don't like
here here's what I don't like when you
when you're walking dude when I was in
Chicago my kind of town so annoying so
annoying um when I was in Chicago
like and even in New York
gonna Wake Up In the City by the way the
city sleeps now after coveted sucks they
go to bed everyone goes to bed in
Chicago no in New York yeah I know I was
quizzing you in Chicago and New York you
know the cell I don't know what's up
with the cell towers but dude it takes
like nine or 12 minutes to [__] if
you're walking like
to get the direction right yeah yeah you
got to be like twisting it and is that
because people
they're constantly trying to keep up
with the amount of data everyone needs
in the city nobody's using [__] at the
same time so Chicago I would use Apple
Maps and it was really hard to do it but
I was walking and then but but I think I
think ways though here's the annoying
thing about Waze first of all right
there's only one so not second of all
but
yeah it tells you how to get there
quicker but you're turning into so many
back roads dude that doesn't happen for
me oh really I go to alternate routes
and it just you can pick from three at
least three yeah and I always pick the
one with the least amount of left turns
but isn't it always why left because
left turns are impossible oh he's smart
he's smart so uh but hold on what about
but usually it's like okay this one and
then it's also this one but plus eight
minutes or this plus 22 minutes those
are the three options yeah like I gotta
go with the first one and then they're
doing so many lifts
not for me this
is not my experience
this is not my experience all right fine
Waze Logan get it together
I don't get it together and use Waze I
don't really have to what's his wife's
name Spencer
all right Lippy Slappy no Samsonite I
think it was slap dude that Parts
Dumber right yeah yeah
um so uh yeah I don't care enough
honestly I use Apple Maps though because
who cares what's gonna make five minutes
ten minutes quicker
hey if I'm late oh well hey dude if I'm
late hey guess what okay now that I'm
here we can start aesthetic matters and
I hate the interface of Apple Maps
aesthetic doesn't matter when you're
trying to get somewhere where you said
it and so I was I want you to know that
all right next one
Matt huge fan uh I'm wearing a wife
beater because it's 85 degrees in this
girl house so take it easy okay uh my
question's for Chris I did my first
three minutes last night I thought it
went pretty well let's talk about checks
told to record myself to go back and
uh critique my performance
at first uh did you find any use in that
or did you kind of just trust yourself
to go out each time
so sad let me know thank you okay so
went on stage then they told him to
record himself
right his self uh Chris I
yeah and then said who's there critique
the people the people that well he said
they he said that he said who cares he
voices in his head
so that he was trying to and they and
they to watch it back and they wanted to
does he find it helpful right that was
the question okay critique himself
um he wants to know if you've recorded
yourself before I did okay so here's
what would happen I would record myself
in the beginning because I thought it
would be a good idea and then I never
really watched it that's so you it is
very me because I think okay so he did
his first three minutes does it help
no the the only thing you got to do in
the beginning is just keep getting on
stage that's it that's it you're not
even writing stuff now that you're going
to be using when you actually become a
real comedian not to say you're not a
real comedian you are a real comedian if
you get on stage and do stand up but
once you start working you're not going
to use this stuff anyway so there's no
reason to understand the beats and [__]
and what you're saying and what you need
to say and not say just get on stage and
get over that getting on stage get over
bombing get over all that stuff so no I
think that it doesn't matter as a matter
of fact I think you're doing yourself a
disservice if you record yourself and
because then you're gonna have the
inkling oh I'm gonna put this online and
it's too early to put anything online
don't get known just work your [__]
that's it that's it there's nothing else
but keep getting on stage you don't have
to record your set maybe I actually
don't think you ever have to record your
set unless you're like I want to shoot
this thing for like you know Comedy
Central or Netflix and I want to get it
tight and you're shooting an hour then
okay but other than that no no the
answer is no I have a question why do so
many upcoming comedians
put
their what they would consider their
best material yeah online it's like
anytime I look at like a comedian with
like you know not so many Instagram
followers but obviously they go up a lot
it's like their whole page
is CL are clips from their material and
isn't that like yeah I don't get that
it's literally going working against
them in a net it it it it it does it's
it kind of sucks because it kind of
sucks for comedians because
not everybody can get specials right of
course and so up until recently the past
year or so people have been putting them
on YouTubes and getting real putting it
on YouTube and getting real numbers on
it and then that leads to sick ticket
sales there's there's the guys who can
get stuff on Netflix they won't do that
and even if they do it doesn't matter
because they get millions of views
anyway right right right but if you got
a guy like
somebody's opening for somebody right
that doesn't have a special they're not
gonna get a special anytime soon okay
and and and it is advantageous for them
to put their stuff online because people
you said is yes okay because people will
find their stuff and be like oh who is
this and then that can lead to ticket
sales okay I mean uh Shane Gillis put
his uh YouTube special or put a special
on YouTube that's it and it it got like
12 million views and I was doing
theaters wow so there's a bunch of
different ways to do that but nobody's
doing that before he just dropped it on
YouTube yeah just without anything I
think so I I don't really know but yeah
so so guy that that does work for people
you know
um
yeah I don't know it does work for
people and so you're asking why they do
that and that's why because there is it
is a little bit like hitting the jackpot
yeah like look Matt Rife who is
um now blew up on Tick Tock you see that
like super handsome guy yeah yeah yeah
why is he so handsome it's it's
confusing yeah he's he's really good too
it's not he's not that's what I'm saying
is weird I know it's it is it is well he
was not handsome when he was started
stand up what yeah well he started when
he was 16 and he was like braces dork
and now he looks like that's hilarious
dude that is it's really funny it's
really fun wow and now he looks like
that and he's and he blew up on Tick
Tock but but the whole thing is he put
out his special on YouTube he was like
you think I'll get a hundred thousand
views oh wow and on my podcast I was
like yo go see this I posted on my thing
taking credit taking credit and it got
and it got a hundred thousand other
people were doing it too I got like 100
000 and he was like why the [__] won't
people you know repost my stuff and this
and that and then went on Tick Tock blue
UPS just sort of putting Clips up blew
up and now everybody is like [__] yeah
go mat [__] those [__] because
Matt's the [__] oh and and he blew up
and now he's got like three million
views on YouTube or something because of
that that's good though yeah it's
awesome so why [__] anybody because they
weren't because they nobody wants to put
their money where their mouth is nobody
wants to be like yeah this guy's funny
or they're or until they're like oh they
blew up and now everybody's on his nuts
it's like [__] that [__] dude I see okay
well now you're getting really really
upset
[__] be down with a
[__] wow Tupac oh wow all right
but do another one [__] mob deep [__]
bad boy breakfast is a regular by and as
a [__] group okay and let's
start that over because Chris was having
a meltdown
cool it's okay
love you guys huge fans everybody says
that but I'm literally the largest fan
to ever have existed probably not but
whatever
um my question is uh I recently so
recently tonight went rollerblading with
my family my mom and my step dad and
um I got pretty good at it fairly
quickly you know I'm 20 22 23. how old
he is 22 23ish um I'm just curious
do I need to be embarrassed at all about
rollerblading and also should I invite
some of my 22-23 year old friends to
come with me or would it be a better
idea for a date is it two out of date
let me know love you guys Chris love you
in New Orleans oh yeah it's a great idea
for a day he should have said I love you
Matt too but he didn't well he didn't
see you in New Orleans but he should
have said maybe I love you Matt dude but
but it's not bad for a date awesome it's
certainly not bad with the family it's
pretty bad if it's just like you and
three guys though [__] I disagree oh
okay I I want a rollerblade crew and
matter of fact I'm gonna start
rollerblading because these guys I have
a buddy I'll be in your group a supreme
blader and he goes to like competitions
and stuff goes backwards and [__] he's
rad at it he like goes he like jumps
what do you call when you jump up and
you like ride along the jump grinding
grinding yeah grinding like like Eric
Nice on the grind
yeah damn grinds dude
going backwards wow oh yeah yeah yeah
what is that song though and why did you
do it I don't know I think Brett Ernst
has a bit on rollerblading and it's
[__] hilarious roller skating
um but yeah dude uh oh there's another
guy Brett Ernst he put his special on
YouTube it's got like three three
million things I know good for him I
know dude are you special
no no it's been around for a while and
now he's doing his his second one or
well I don't know it's the second one on
YouTube but yeah
yeah I'm Brett I haven't seen Brett in
like a decade
yeah he's great he's a great guy a lot
of white guys are doing the YouTube
thing because [__] everyone wants
like you know Indian Standard
convenience now anyway let's go next one
hey Chris this is a question for you
okay well I guess I'll just go home
Billy I live in Odessa Texas so I'll see
you in Midland on March 24th nice and a
couple of our friends oh yeah we're
super stoked
um I need advice on parenting stuff I'm
not a parent yet uh but we we do plan on
having kids in the future and I'm so
pumped for that nice the only thing I'm
not ready for is when my kid walks up to
me and says Dad I float up because I
have a weak stomach I can't handle
follow-up okay wow anytime I see
somebody on TV do it I have to mute it
and look away if somebody does it to me
and it's in like in the same room I have
to run out of the room because I'm
starting to gag and like driving stuff
and I know that the day is going to come
when my kid comes up to me and says I
wrote up so Chris you as a father we as
a future father how how do I handle
follow-up how do I not throw up cleaning
the flow up deaf
anyway
um any tips and tricks on that would be
greatly appreciated and I'll see you in
the middle on March 24th my you got to
get over it grow up I know how even
though you didn't ask me you dick right
grow up rhymes with throw up grow up
yeah grow you got to get over it
actually unfortunately you gotta just
get over it oh you're an adult oh oh
grow up yeah so I was gonna throw up
when I first time I ever threw up my dad
knew how scared I was and uh that I
wouldn't do it in the toilet and my dad
said just throw up on me and he said I
went like this and threw up all over his
chest you know that would it have would
it did it make you feel better it made
me feel comfortable I think he describes
this it made me feel comfortable like oh
if I could do it on him it must not be
that big of a deal okay you know Dad's
disgusting and I've been doing ever
since hey Dad you're disgusting if I
have to throw up I drive over to Mommy
and Daddy's house I'm gonna throw up all
over my dad
um yeah dude uh yeah I think you got to
get over it man you got and you know
what actually you know what I'm actually
I'm not worried about you because
you learn a lot from your kids and you
are going to figure out how to do this
and when your son has to throw up that's
going to help you get over your throw-up
thing because that's your son that's
your flesh and blood you need to get
over it because he needs you do it how
about that and right now you're probably
like oh okay that makes sense I don't
know if I could do it but I'm telling
you right now you don't even know how
much he needs you and you don't even
know how much because you don't know how
much you need him and when he comes out
you'll see and he's going to throw up
and it'll be just fine I'm not even
worried about it okay but also I would
say I'm guessing that when your son
throws up you go like this is gonna be
that gross to you but that's kind of
what I'm saying it's not what you're
saying that's what I said it is what I'm
saying it's not what you're saying it's
what I'm saying because I'm the one who
said it I said yeah we were around it
you'll see that I'm the one who said
that and not you
you said a different thing so that's why
you said that's the thing you said but
that's what I'm saying though is because
it's his son and it's going to be okay
and you you just don't even worry about
I'm not worried about you I said but
what I said is because it's your son
it's not even going to go throughout in
the first place so you're good because
I'm not worried but that's why I'm not
worried about you wow
he just needs to have said what I said
you know
all right well he's fine and grow up and
he's fine okay who else we got well it's
over
same guy what's up Chris what's up Matty
I'm here with the puppy hey I got a
question for y'all really how should I
handle this situation
I work at a restaurant with this guy
that walks up to the bathroom stall
while you're trying to poop
and he'll lean up against the stall and
start tapping his foot and humming or
whistling
like he's in a [__] 80s movie
and for me I'm trying to sit private
yeah while I'm doing my thing I can't
really make a bowel movement with
somebody that's standing two feet away
from me so
pretty much everybody at the restaurant
has said something about it we all think
it's weird nobody wants to say anything
to him so
just wondering uh how I should approach
this
uh yeah love the podcast y'all life ribs
Booyah Booyah and hell yeah dude that
was cool what I don't understand is what
the guy's doing does he have to go no no
no no he's being like oh he thinks he's
being funny first of all uh but he's
like getting close to the stall tapping
on it and like being a he said 80s movie
because it's like a bully thing right
but he doesn't want to fight up but what
I don't just know but what I don't
understand is why is everyone unwilling
to say something to this guy when a
everyone agrees but B so power numbers
but B
that sucks what and everyone would agree
so next time he does it say get away I'm
trying to take a generation
Matt or whatever you know use the actual
word if you want but just be like what
do you make them feel here's what you
want to do you want to make them feel
stupid you don't just want to let him
know he needs to stop you want to make
him feel stupid so you got to have the
right tone of voice and you got to be
like what what are you doing dude yeah
like are you a [__] infant what is
wrong with you get the [__] out of here
everyone hates you because you do this
get out wow and then that he would never
do it again
he'll get fired yeah but does he want
that well no just got to be like Yo dude
you gotta stop hanging out where
everyone's [__] yeah that's so weird
it is really what I would I would be
like hey man what are you doing is it
funny exactly that's why I don't
understand do you want to fight it seems
like you're a bully but I don't get I
don't want to fight I just want to [__]
yeah I don't want to fight I just want
to [__] that's like a rap song yeah
I don't know dude that's weird be like
hey if you're gonna stand out there what
come in wipe my ass dude right or
that's a weird thing bro
[__] on the guy's car I mean where were
you for this one no then when he gets
mad be like I didn't know where else
this [__] is the only place I knew you
weren't because yeah yeah yeah you're
working so I was [__] on your door
handle yeah
yeah
that's annoying dude one time I was
coming out of a anti-social weird like
that's like uh yeah that guy's gonna
kill somebody or something like that's
so weird
by the time I came out of a mall and
there was a homeless guy pissing on my
car no way yep waited for him to finish
oh why he was homeless it's like what's
where's this leading to
getting him to stop pissing on your car
I guess yeah but like
then what he turns around and pisses all
over me and [__] like I'm just all right
just pissed I was just like all right I
mean I guess you know what maybe I would
do the same thing but I don't think I
think I would have reacted too quickly
to catch myself before I didn't I'm good
I'm good at that you're not good at that
I'm worse at that yeah I am worse at
that I was joking but now I feel bad but
yeah I was just like no it's all right I
have a temper
yeah
okay but you you think you have worse
number than me
I have a worse temper than you you get
way more mad about [__] that is very
stupid and doesn't matter
I snap yeah you know what I'm talking
about you don't snap right true I snap
true
I'm supposed to be snapped uh
uh a second ago come on
um
it's been a while I mean I've been
working on this one actually that's the
reason I started going to therapy yeah
you started going to therapist therapy
because it was because I when I I was
getting uh just imagine you know when I
was dating her okay and trying not to
name any names okay it sounded like the
reverse of the [__] you did you were
dating [__]
and she was like you know you have a
real
anger problem you really snap at me and
I was like yeah but you do stuff wrong
oh and she was like yeah but even even
if I die okay you snap that's not the
best way to deal with it I was like you
know what you're absolutely right so I
started going to therapy been with the
same therapist for women can really push
a very long time over a decade
women can really push your buttons wow
sleeper well so you've been to the
therapist for over a decade and do you
snap less oh my God so much oh wow yeah
yeah yeah so much less oh man that's
good yeah it's good damn I don't really
snap too much you don't snap but I do
often feel anger and upset yeah you'll
like text me and be like this is a yeah
[__] and I'll be like that's not
even a thing to recognize and being
different about let alone be very deeply
upset about that's not true you get so
mad when like somebody tells you to take
your feet off furniture oh dude that is
such a [__] [__] thing that
people do nah yeah it is because nine
times out of ten they're not even the
person who owns the place
that's asinine to be somewhere that you
don't own so what are they doing that's
making a statement about
I I think hey you should take your foot
off the thing and I mean I'm talking
about patrons of places come up to me
and tell me that I'm talking about the
the waiter or like you don't give a [__]
you just want to be a dick and by the
way I'm doing this
I was like it's not like I'm like on the
walls just
you know Lionel Richie and [__] yeah I'm
not [__] Jamiroquai
it's so annoying dude it's actually
Lionel Richie not did you remember quite
no he's like going back and forth you
know he walks all over you walk on the
ceiling too dude all right so sue me so
sue me so it's like it's really annoying
when people dude last time the person
did it a woman came up to me she was
like 70 years old it was at a doctor's
office and I was just doing that and she
was like I think this young man should
take his foot off the and I'm like you
know what dude it's not 1940 anymore you
don't have to be like you probably
thinks I'm I have a motorcycle because I
have tattoos you know it's like get with
the [__] times man okay well
it's deeper no it's not it's just let me
live dude yeah people like a real weird
hang up about that and I don't get it
but to get no but to get mad about it is
absolutely pointless either keep your
foot up or take it down don't let it
matter so you're okay with people
telling you what to do like that yeah
because I don't have to do it
I don't have to do what people tell me
to do so I don't care what they say
unless they're figures of authority if a
cop did it that was the other story if a
cop did it that would bother me if some
old lady who I don't give a [__] about
tells me to do something I don't know if
the cops did get your foot off the thing
that would bother that would be even
worse dude I had a cop uh once in I was
just getting I was leaving a Yankee game
getting on a subway coming back uh to
where I live in New York and um
I
I swiped the metro card to get on the
subway station subway platform and uh
there's at certain places certain areas
depends on the subway station but
sometimes there's Metro cards it's like
everywhere on the ground yeah
like on your phone right
um and I and I swiped and I just flung
It On The Ground yeah yeah because
that's what seemingly a thousand people
and uh some guy
with a shaved head and like a Hawaiian
shirt on comes up to me and he's and he
says would you treat your mother's house
like that
and I was like what
I actually did I was so surprised I
didn't know what he was talking about
yeah yeah yeah and then he indicates the
floor what I did and he just repeats
himself would you treat your mother's
house like that yeah and I actually
thought about it and I said
yeah I think so right like that's what I
did isn't even like I didn't spit on
right before right or like wipe my ass
with a comforter you know I threw a
metro card on the on the floor and it
was an outside station too yeah oh wow
anyway he didn't even reveal that he was
a cop entrapment and so
but I snapped back at him if I knew it
was a cop I wouldn't have done of course
but uh this is what anyway yeah exactly
he takes he takes his badge out of his
shirt and he shows it to me like I'm
supposed to
yeah give a [__] what because what are
you gonna do arrest me I mean do
whatever they want though you know they
didn't do [__] because you can't I mean
I guess he could get me for littering
but I would just go to court take a
picture of the [__] floor and go to
court and say look there's a thousand
other ones yeah I thought this is what
you're supposed to do yeah get out of
jail free yeah exactly okay so anyway
I'm the [__] man that's the end of
the story and then you're the man the
[__] man
um
wow
that is my point is that's mad annoying
it pissed me off that a cop was like
flexing his authority over some [__]
like that I don't know man but if some
guy did that it'd be like uh-huh and
keep going
I get it I get it I get what you're
saying yeah but both are bad both are
bad but but it's not worth my time to be
annoyed by some guy who thinks I
shouldn't have done what I did I do not
care enough what that [__] random guy
thinks you should have told him you
should have said it was racism that he
was doing it he was white yeah but he
doesn't know what you are
okay or something yep you're profiling
me you're a white guy am I am I a White
Guy this is a Melting Pot and everyone's
kind of you know wow everyone's mixed in
a way and you don't know what my
background worst argument worst [__]
argument ever I do look Middle Eastern
though I think you should have said what
he said would you treat your mother's
house like that I'd be like well let me
I said let me come over your mom says
I'll show you how to shoot yours
freeze you get arrested again a Hawaiian
shirt why didn't he just show me his bad
first like what a dick extra dick you
know the whole thing is gonna be
undercover he definitely saw like nine
episodes of SVU he was binging it and
then Kate and then was like I'm gonna do
something and then had to go somewhere
and then saw that and was like cool you
know it was even more amazing he had his
partner with him and his partner I could
tell is like oh wow this [__] clown
oh so the guy's like just got in a fight
with his wife then yeah he's having a
bad day yeah and he took it out on me
you love those kinds of guys you know
yeah but now when they're doing it yeah
uh uh his partner was black though his
partner was like yeah you should have
been like he would actually do it we
deal with this a lot
no he was like looking at me like yeah
not like what did you do kid you know I
know sorry yeah dude because he's always
trying to I can't imagine what he's like
if he's treating me like this what he
treats you like right well right right
yeah I mean I'm white but yeah
but yeah but you have to disclose that
to him oh okay and be like oh I didn't
do all these why don't you go and get
all these [__] you know I'm
white but there's one thing everybody
knows I'm not and that's black you know
so I couldn't do that to a black guy
maybe if it was Middle Eastern I could
have been like we we get persecuted like
this you know okay all right next one
hey Matt hey Chris this is Sabrina
coming at you from the Bay Area hey
so I'm gonna get straight into it I have
a friend who facetimes me unannounced
all the time
like every couple of days just facetimes
me I could be working I could be
chilling at home I could be at the
grocery store I could be at my
boyfriend's house she just facetimes me
without asking
um we used to work together for a few
years and became friends and now we
don't work together so we don't see each
other very often maybe you know once a
month but if you're gonna FaceTime me
I'm the type of person that like I need
you to have something to say like it's
got to be important or you got to ask me
a question really quick but usually when
I answer the phone or answer FaceTime
she's just like hey and she's just like
in her kitchen with her dog like
chilling and then it turns into a really
long conversation that I don't want to
have
um that's her point I don't want to be a
bad friend uh she's really bad at
texting so maybe that's why she
facetimes me because she forgets to
respond but get better at texting I
don't know how to approach it I don't
know how to be like hey dude I don't
want to FaceTime you a lot of the times
I just don't answer so uh what do you
guys think I should do my uh uh sounds
like you're doing it right not answering
but if you have to say something say hey
I don't ever pick up when people
FaceTime me unless it's a plan um which
is what I say if someone facetimes me
and I don't pick up and then they say
they try again or try again later I just
text them at some point or let them know
next time I see them I say hey
I don't want you to take offense I never
ever ever answer face times
unless it we have a plan to FaceTime at
that time it's weird though because
that's a very young thing to do she
seems very young by the way nice hat
she's got the life rips bucket yeah
um but you but it's it is
um I like how it matched her eyeshadow I
noticed it [__] details but I do yeah
very very noticeable song
This is How I was watching Colombo and
there was a picture of this guy uh dead
and um it was a picture of his
um hand and they were like well the
reason why we got Colombo is because he
notices all of the details and he was
like you mean how I noticed that there's
a a tan line where his watch should be
he wears a watch but it's not on it was
like it was a picture of the guy's tan
line so
um Columbo is great but so stupid
sometimes yeah so anyway uh yeah I don't
the FaceTime thing is it's Bonkers to me
it is I'm gonna go here's this it's so
much harder to talk on FaceTime than it
is to talk on the phone like texting the
phone sucks phone to FaceTime is beyond
here's why you gotta [__] not only
focus on the conversation you also got
to be holding your [__] up like this
it's annoying as [__] or like this and
they say up your nose in your brain dude
it's so face time is so annoying don't
ever FaceTime me people I got two three
people that FaceTime me and I'm just
like all right what's up okay bye you
know we talking this [__] and we could
have done this on text you let them do
that to you yeah I mean you know I I try
to because I'm like maybe I'll get used
to it honestly I don't I do it with my
wife and kid on when I'm on the road
well obviously yeah yeah of course but
that's totally different but that is
just a niche Niche got it empty out
that's so bad you gotta
I think that you need to I think that
FaceTime should only be reserved for
something where you need to see
somebody's face for it like I gotta tell
you something very serious or or if it's
if it's if it's really someone you
deeply care about and they don't live
near you yeah and it's like hey can we
FaceTime
on this day so I can look at you and I
miss you that's exactly that's that's
what FaceTime is for yeah remember the
first of the original FaceTime
commercials it was like specifically
like Grandma and Grandpa live across the
country and this couple had a baby and
now they get to look at each other
that's why FaceTime is good not to see
some guy you're like kind of friends
with who wants to just like chat for 12
minutes
yeah dude one time I was in my car I got
a [__] phone call from an unknown
number picked it up it was Jeremy Renner
why he was laughing so hard at my
podcast about him and he was like bro
you're so funny man and I was like what
the there's the most Hollywood thing of
all time you picked up I picked up
because of a text from a friend that was
like yo pick this up or something and I
picked up and it was Jeremy Renner I was
driving wow and he was crying laughing
and he was like I heard you were talking
about me on my podcast and I was like oh
no I love Crystal he was like this sucks
I was like I thought he was talking [__]
and then I listened to it man it's
hilarious dude wow wow really yeah dude
it was the funniest thing I couldn't
believe it dude so it was happening that
was your we were talking about my face
yeah dude I know a lot of famous people
man now you're just bragging yeah yeah
yeah yeah uh
um about him when he got hit by a tree
how about that yeah that sucks man you
think I'm gonna use the FaceTime then
from him did you think about that yep do
you think about that did you think about
that time he called you when you saw you
got hit by a tree
yeah probably eventually yeah pretty sad
yep is he okay
I wrote him and I said are you okay dude
I'm thinking about you he said thanks
needed it so I fixed him with my
thoughts basically
so stupid no he got [__] up though
yeah he was mad [__] up he got [__]
up he almost did like uh Sonny Bono did
you know
some trees like Eminem did it he got he
got Sonny Bono got hit by a tree Jeremy
Renner got hit by a tree Natasha
Richardson got hit by a tree you're not
getting you know they're hitting trees
my principle they're not like zombies no
but actually my principal in second
grade really did get hit by a tree she
got hit by a tree everybody hated her so
much a tree fell on her before school
one day okay and they came in to make an
announcement and all the kids were like
Yay because they didn't really
understand they just they we all took it
as like oh she's not coming back to
school yay but we actually were
applauding like demons for a woman who
had a tree fall on her
you're terrible not a skiing accident
just a tree fell on it terrible she died
the only other face times I get was from
Jaden Smith
oh
I don't know what it is it's like a
famous person thing to do
no not in my case I don't do it and I'm
[__] extremely famous but Jaden Smith
random people do it to me and think it's
totally normal who are the people in
those people's lives who act like it's
normal it to me it's like the same
people but it's like the same thing as
like a really really really bad kisser
like how who have you been kissing that
has been letting you think wow it's okay
to kiss like that it's the same idea who
are you friends with that has been
letting you think it's okay to FaceTime
me out of the [__] blue
who are you
Zachary Levi too okay
and I just don't understand what the
people who I always say the people that
I face you're right
you're right exactly Levi facetimed you
yeah okay he could have faced on me too
no but I don't understand what the
famous thing is because like I will say
the people who FaceTime me I would say
60 of them are famous or more but also
like a lot of people you know are famous
so that's that's true I do hobnob with
the Elise stupid I
hate
yourself you if you hate yourself I hate
you too oh I hate it what like people
who are famous in being famous in those
events and [__] hey oh you're famous
though so how do you feel about yourself
I want I want to be a comedian I want
people to come to my shows and like
think I'm funny I don't want people to
be like
that's a celebrity I don't I don't like
celebrities Hollywood sucks yeah
Hollywood it's Hollywood basically you
know there's one way to know that
Hollywood sucks now um
not that it was ever like amazing it was
always a bunch of pieces of [__] being
pieces of [__] right they used to make
better [__] but that's not what I'm
saying right the people in Hollywood are
so [__] and this is how you know
the slap thing Will Smith slaps Chris
Rock which is just across the board
[__] terrible yeah it's awful
he wins like five minutes later and
everybody there gives him a standing
ovation right which they don't give for
anyone else who won an award that night
what the [__] what the
f is that they don't know what to do
everything that though because they're
lost and that's literally signaling the
worst possible thing
they're idiots dude they're idiots so
idiotic they're idiots dude they're
idiots dude if somebody punches somebody
you escort them out no matter where you
know they are apparently they tried but
he was like no I'm not going anywhere
and they made it an executive decision
they like didn't want to make a scene
really yeah so they were like they had
that it's like the Cloverfield Lane
don't be a guy who's like do you know
that for real though where did you oh
really where did you hear that don't be
like that okay but I want to do my own
research because I don't know then after
you talk to me go do your own research
But realize that I'm [__] right okay
but there's all also other stuff out
there that could be misinformation yeah
I know and I'm not gonna believe
anything to not give it to you how about
that okay you read it where I I read a
[__] interview with the guy who did
it okay okay
[Laughter]
all right damn I'm old now I can't laugh
without coughing like I can't laugh
really hard without coughing so then
what so the guy went up to Will Smith
and said Sir Mr Smith uh we wanna I
don't know how we said it right yeah
whatever and Will was like no I'm not
going you can you can like drag me out
of here but I'm not I'm not gonna go
with you and they were like oh I'm not
gonna obviously the director was like
well I don't want to like
get a guy sent out in [__] handcuffs
or whatever risk another big [__]
Fiasco like they had no choice but to
kind of let him sit there like a
complete
[__] [__] next time Jaden
facetimes you ask him what the [__] is
wrong with his dad well obviously
everyone's fighting their own war and
they got their own demons and like I
don't think that you know that's not an
excuse to get up on stage slots but I'm
sure if you asked Will Smith is it he
would say no I [__] up and I don't I I
believe that you know what but he only
thinks he [__] up because everyone
else said that and he realized his
career is [__] up now so he needs to
act like he thinks he last that night he
was like
singing and dancing to get jiggy with it
that night yeah yeah that's what I'm
saying I think if you do a bad thing is
when you should feel bad but no I think
that if you were to ask Will Smith
before all this happened is it right to
go up and smack somebody even if they
talk about your wife I feel like you
would be like no that's wrong correct so
I agree well not correct but I think it
got the best of him and he was in his
own world that we know nothing about and
he went up and did that and that's a
shame but I think that he thinks it's a
shame but he didn't even say that when
he had the chance when he won an Oscar
he was still buzzing off of that though
he was I want to be a river to my people
remember or whatever whatever well okay
but I understand what you're saying
but what okay first of all he was so mad
mad enough to do what he did okay so he
was not so that's where he was mentally
that angry and then he won an Oscar so
then he thought oh wow I'm on top of the
world we don't know what that's like I
feel like it was too much going on for
somebody to handle I also feel like Will
Smith has probably been living that way
for 40 years we don't know what this
[__] does to people and how it affects
them dude Fame is [__] up no I know
I'm I mean I'm I'm famous and so and I'm
not excusing what he did but I don't
think he kind of are getting close to it
no I'm not I think it's [__] up yeah I
think it's [__] up I think it's really
[__] up you know you don't go around
smacking people also I'm a comedian [__]
Will Smith for that Chris Rock it's like
but also now Chris Rock has to forever
be associated with but Chris Rock is
that here's the deal yes that does suck
that [__] sucks and Chris Rock is
bigger than that though he's gonna be
okay if it was somebody like me then I
would be the guy who got [__] stopped
by Will Smith right you know what I mean
if I'm in a Tom Segura but Chris Rock is
Chris Rock yeah so I think it'll be okay
it sucks it's unfortunate but I you know
Chris will turn into something hilarious
because he's [__] hilarious he's a
new special like really soon right yeah
and uh and it sucks and I'm not excusing
it but it's just like
you know and obviously Will Smith's fine
he's in another movie in emancipation
he's [__] killing it perfect movie to
come out after that happen you know you
know what I mean it is it's like not
like [__] men in black seven it's
like but nobody saw it everyone hates
him now it's crazy no I said it true I
said it so it's true it's not true huh
you'd be surprised when I say something
is true no I I think that you say a lot
of true stuff I'm not I'm just saying I
agree
everyone thinks that too well I I here's
what I think with cancer culture the way
it is I do think the way it tracks that
Will Smith should have had some sort of
repercussions but I also you know know
he'd [__] I guess he didn't like he
kind of did but not real ones like he
got kicked out of the something he got
kicked out of the academy who got
disinvited from the Oscars for like five
years you [__] cares and that's kind
of nothing that's not being canceled
that's just right that's the consequence
yeah
um so yeah uh I don't know I I I I I
think it's weird that you know people I
mean people [__] people get kids for way
less than that yeah so yeah I don't know
it's all backwards but you know I it's
uh yeah Crystal turned into something
great he's [__] hilarious dude and
and he'll be fine and he uh obviously
and I honestly his ticket sales spiked
so hard after that yeah that's the only
Silver Lining but I knew that before I
knew that and then you want a one-on-one
session with your [__] boy
bad about it okay
I'm shooting my special in Minneapolis
chrysalia.com go get those tickets are
gonna be in Midland I'm also going to be
in Utah uh and oh oh and you know what
I'm actually doing a show in Oxnard and
Brea and Irvine leading up to this
special to get ready for it and then
also I'm that's in California and then
also I'm in gonna be in Milwaukee uh and
Austin chrisley.com
if you have a question about you what
you mean is if you have a question for
us on the show oh yeah click the link in
the description below or go to watch
lifeline.com if you want that paper
merch got a life on merch.com
all right guys thanks
[Music]
please hello hello